thank you hi hi daughter I have a
question my husband had Gideon beret
syndrome he's aged 73 he's 6 foot 1
he weighs 276 pounds while he's now
recuperating he's having a lot of nerve
problems every night like sometime in
his speech he gets uh sensation like
someone's pulling on his feet or his
legs and his hands so even though he's
getting better he still has to treat
which they're going to try to remove
within the next month or so
what do you mean he's got the trait
without her I remove this well when he
got too dirty in bere syndrome that they
had to insert a trait for him to breathe
okay now did you have a fever did you
have an infection post-surgery maybe
well why usually when you have Gambari
syndrome it's a result of something else
well they are thinking and I don't know
if I can say this on the air they think
it was from a vaccination shot and
they're trying to link it up to that
okay that means they don't know that
means they don't know and they're
groping around okay right
all right oh all right no how is he now
is he sleeping well or what
he's sleeping well except for when that
nerves and his feet start to react okay
now let me ask you another question here
does he have a history of any back
problems like in a car wreck or falling
off a ladder anything like that uh he
was in a car wreck many years ago yeah
okay well he's got a back problem okay
was what the problem is
and that will result in what's called
sciatica were squeezing the found herbs
coming out from between the lumbar
vertebrae which are the sciatic nerves
go down into the legs and the feet that
can cause numbness tingling burning as
really miserable stuff and of course
this is something where he has to be
real careful because they're gonna start
doing a bunch of expensive tests and
dangerous tests and things it was really
very simple
okay so Charmaine yes what did you do
remote means repair of his disk between
his vertebrae his vert has his bones and
what would you do about his weight six
foot one he's 276 he's probably 70
pounds overweight Yeah right
it is weight I would give him for those
issues I would give him three healthy
bone and joint packs but to lose weight
he could take the Rev okay yeah he could
go at three healthy brain heart packs
definitely I'm gonna go 300 Ranger hard
packs and then getting the gluco gel he
get three two large bottles of gluco gel
so it could take 20 a day five breakfast
five at lunch five at dinner five at
bedtime or he could take a two of the
large bowel lukkage else we can take 15
a day five it practice five at lunch
five it's anything in a quart bottle of
the liquid glucose I'll take an ounce of
the liquid with a half a glass of water
bedtime and I would have him take one of
the bottles of Rev dropper full under
his tongue thirty minutes for each meal
I leave it absorbs your old socials and
he'll begin to lose a half pound two
pounds a day and for the sort of gamma
ray syndrome thing which is doctors want
you to think these things are caused by
vaccinated no he he's got he's got a
back problem here is what his problem is
and so what would you do in addition to
the gluco gel what would you do for to
really enhance that what would you do to
make the gluco gel
[Music]
much better for real eating team what
would you put on top of me what would
you rub on his back to relieve pain
inflammation well I I would get some cm
cream and put some trauma oil in it and
put it on topically wear this and that
will definitely help yeah that would be
the lumbar vertebra his lower back from
his ribs down to his tailbone right down
the middle and an inch on either side
and so he would need probably two of the
wide mouth jars four months of the CM
cream and he would need two little 10 ml
bottles of the trommel all blend of
aromatherapy oil to actually relieve
paint put five drops in every teaspoon
of the same cream apply it as a lumbar
area the vertebrae and guess what the
symptoms will go away and take the
supplement program the body will rebuild
it